This video is made possible
by Shaker and spoon,
Shaker and spoon and send out a cocktail
box each month with the ingredients
needed to make bar quality
cocktails in your own home.
Yeah,
$20 off your first box by going to
Shaker in the spoon.com forward slash.
Biographics.
There's a link below.
Liar does some males.
It on was a much loved revolutionary
hero who saved China from the rule of
foreign aggresses.
He multiplies China by bringing the ones
as of western industrialized nation to
their shores to others.
Though he is remembered for
being a sociopathic Tyron
to sacrifice the lives of
millions of people in order to bring
his political experiment to life.
In the video today,
the life of the chairman,
a farmer and land owner named
Malley Chan was a self made man.
He was born into poverty,
but he worked hard and saved enough
to buy two acres of rice patties.
Over the years he employed workers
tens the lands for him and most of his
profits went back into expanding his farm.
He builds a comfortable life for his
wife when she may and their future
children.
Sadly,
his wife had difficulty getting pregnant
and she lost her first two children
during infancy.
She gave birth to her only child
mouths and Dong in 1883 growing up,
Mousa Dong lived very comfortable
life compared to his peers.
It was not uncommon for Chinese children
do walk around without shoes and wear
clothes that were in tatters.
They barely had enough food to eat and
they could not afford proper healthcare.
The fact that males are dongs parents
could afford to provide all of the basic
necessities for their child is why some
people considered them to be wealthy.
The one thing that Mouser Dong had in
common with all of the children in China
though was that he was taught the
religion and philosophy of Confucianism.
One of his most well known teachings is
that everyone should try to go with the
flow means balance,
the energy of ying and Yang.
When it came to the government,
Confucius said that people should try to
be satisfied with their lot in life and
they should know their place in
order for society to run smoothly.
Confucius says there is governments when
the prince is Prince and the minister
is minister.
When the father,
his father,
and the son,
his son,
however males are Dong,
did not agree with
everything Confucius taught.
After all,
he knew from firsthand experience that
his father was able to work his way out
of poverty.
He wanted to believe that he could grow
up to be more than just a farmer's son
in school.
Males that Dorman was one of the top
students in his class and he loved reading
as many books as he could
get his hands on butts.
At 13 years old,
his parents,
they removed him from his elementary
school in order to help his father work on
the farm.
His father tried to arrange a marriage
with a young girl named [inaudible] who
was the daughter of a nearby
farmer and land owner.
This would have ended his education
and completely sealed his fate.
He refused to marry
hard at 16 years of age.
He convinced his parents that he wanted
to be an intellectual and his parents
agreed to send him to a boarding
school and the city of Chang sharp.
When he was in this city,
he met other blank minded people who
believed that there was a need to change
the Chinese way of life
in the 18 hundreds China,
we're seeing more and more trade from
western countries from 1842 1842 Cheyenna
in Great Britain.
They had a big conflict known as the
opium wars and it's trying to lost.
After signing the treaty of Nanking,
Hong Kong became a British territory
and European traders now had access to
Chinese ports.
Even though this one's a peace treaty,
the Chinese people nicknames this,
the unequal treaties because it appeared
as though the Ching Dynasty was bowing
to the demands of Great Britain.
China was far from being
an industrialized nation.
That technology was so far
behind the rest of the world.
It was far too easy for western
countries to take advantage.
In 1895 Japan attempted to overpower
China and ran their influence over Korea
and this was known as the
first sign Japanese war.
The Cherry on top of an already bad
situation came in the year 1908 when the
emperor passed away.
I'm the only male out of the Ching
Dynasty was a two year old named per year.
It's not a surprise that people began to
lose their faith in the strength of the
dynasty in 1911 and Mouser
dawn was 18 years old.
The in high revolution happens and the
People's Republic of China broaden ends
to the Ching Dynasty
off the switching to
the People's republic.
The overarching government with calls
the Kuomintang also known as the
nationalist party or the KMT.
The Kuomintang allowed warlords to
rule over their perspective territories
across China.
Each warlord had the power
to create their own laws,
charge taxes,
and raise their own armies as a
university student mows it on.
His favorite subject was philosophy.
He read the wealth of nations by
Adam Smith and the spirits of laws by
Montesquieu.
He also read all of the works
of the Chinese revolutionaries
who were behind the
People's republic.
During this time,
he created the Association for Students,
self government and said who non fast
normal university so that students could
have a voice to protest
against the school rules.
He also formed a student volunteer army.
The Greeks had around 80 members and
they all shared their ideas on government
and philosophy.
It was during this time that Mouser don
was introduced to the work of Karl Marx.
Out of all the political
philosophies they studied,
he and his friends agreed
with the ideas of communism.
This was because it promised that every
person in society would have their basic
needs met now's it don't continue to
excel in school and he was number three in
his graduating class.
He got a job at Beijing University as a
librarian where he was able to read as
many books as his heart desired.
The Communist Party of China or CCP was
established in 1921 one of the founders
lead does how was a librarian
at Peking University.
The other was Chen duck sue,
who was an intellectual who had been a
part of the People's Republic of China.
After seeing how,
trying to adjust to the new republic
docs who believed that the warlords were
taking advantage of the peasant class
and that the political system needed
adjusting,
he thought communism would actually
be better for that society.
Now's the Dong was just 28 years old
at the time and he was one of the many
young people who began attending
communist meetings after work.
Once people began to learn about
the teachings of Karl Marx,
the Communist Party of China
gains a huge following.
Many peasant people were unhappy with
their respective warlords and they wanted
a new system of governments.
Of course,
communism was posing a huge threat to the
nationalist party and like the rest of
the parties in the republic,
communism actually had the potential
to spread across the entire country and
replace them as the leading party.
They believed it was time to get rid
of the communists in China before they
gains too much power.
In 1927 and gang working for the KMT
attacked and killed members of the
Communist Party,
or they announced the plan to eradicate
every single member of the CCP.
This events is remembered as
the Shanghai massacre role.
The April the 12th patch over 300,000
communists were killed and 50,000 people
denounced fat party
affiliation out of fear.
The Shanghai massacre is credited
with starting the Chinese civil war.
Since the KMT was the original
party of the Republic of China,
they felt that it was time for them to
eliminate the feudal system of warlords
and the communists as well in order to
unite all of China under one government.
In 1931 when Mouser Dong was 48 years old,
he was elected as the chairman
of the Communist Party.
In 1934 the Chinese civil war was still
raging on miles and on led the members
of the Communist Party and what
is remembered as the Long March.
They tracked over 4,000 miles through
mainland China in their attempts to fend
off KMT forces.
The leader of the Nationalist Party,
Chiang Kai Shek was sending troops
after the communists and he ran several
campaigns and his attempts to defeat them
mows the dawn did not have an army as
large as the KMT,
but he had his charisma
wherever they went.
He used his power of persuasion to
tell the villages that communism would
improve their lives.
He promised them that they
would never go hungry again.
People are so unhappy living under the
rule of their warlords that it wasn't
very hard to convince people to fight
for the cause after losing thousands of
men and battles that don would just
restock his army with new peasants in the
next village and just
keep on marching forward.
In 1937 all of China would have to hit
pause on their civil war because Japan
was taking advantage of the
chaos by invading Manchuria.
This was known as the
second Sino Japanese war.
For years,
Japan was attempted to take
over Chinese territories.
The Japanese,
they tortured,
they killed,
they raped Chinese civilians everywhere
they went and decimated the Chinese
major cities,
the armies of the warlords in the KMT,
they were already a,
from the losses they sustained
while fighting each other.
There was no way they could fend off
the Japanese empire on their own.
The leader of the KMT Chiang Kai Shek
had to swallow his pride and ask the
Communist Party for help if they're
red army was growing in numbers.
They defended China against the Japanese
and what is known as the hundred
regiments offensive.
The Red Army was largely made up of
peasants who didn't have time for proper
military training,
so mouser on used
guerrilla warfare tactics.
They also called in some help of the
USSR who closed in on Japanese occupied
Manchuria from the sidewall.
China is on the other.
They succeeded in saving the country.
However,
once the Japanese were gone,
the civil war,
it was back in 1946 miles a dog and
his Red Army defeated the Campti and it
became the new rulers of China.
At this point,
people for Mouser Dong was a national
hero and the rightful leader of that
country.
Not only did he save
them from the Japanese,
but the also unified the
country under one rule.
For the first time
since the Ching Dynasty,
people were hopeful that things would
finally start to change for the better,
but actually they were going
to get a whole lot worse.
In 1958 miles are Dong
officially began his plan.
This was called the great leap forward.
This was his attempt to use communist
ideals to bring modern industrialization
to China.
He might've had the best
intentions at heart,
but may matter how many books one may
read about creating a new society.
There is a huge difference between theory
and actually doing something in real
life.
The greater need forward created a
major land reform where citizens,
we're no longer allowed
to own private property.
Farmers had to give up their lands
to the greater good of the public.
They still have to work,
but they were not allowed to keep the
food they were growing because the rules
dictated that people who were far more
important to society deserve nourishment
first and that the peasants could
be fed with whatever was leftover.
He sent medical services do all Chinese
villagers ensuring that all of the
citizens have healthcare and they
were fit enough to do manual labor.
He commands it.
Many of the people of
China to start constructing
factories and new governmental
buildings.
Most peasants weren't farmers their
entire lives and they had no idea how to
work in a factory.
Still they,
they were expected to produce steel
and other industrialized materials.
There were so many people
now working in factories.
It was impossible to properly train or
manage everyone despite having a lot of
issues getting adjusted to
the new policy of the plan.
It actually worked for a
very short window of time.
Crop production went up
and people were healthy.
Aaron's had more food
to eat than ever before.
Despite the setbacks.
The Chinese people were also able to Iraq,
a few modern buildings.
This progress,
it all came crashing down
in less than a year ago.
This happened in the winter of 1959
miles or dawn had suggested that farmers
grow more grain and this
was stored in silos.
However,
without grabbing other types of
food to store for the winter months,
it men,
the people were to survive
only on bread and the winter.
The weather that year,
it was awful as well.
They experienced widespread droughts,
followed by massive typhoons that caused
the flooding that destroyed crops,
tigers,
leopards,
and wolves were attacking farmers as
they tried to cultivate more lands.
Therefore,
mal created an antipasto campaign where
he encouraged people to shoot these
animals on site and eat their meat.
This push tigers and leopards near
extinction as people killed 75% of their
population.
The great leap forward with actually a
huge step backwards for China and is it
created a widespread famine
that killed millions of people.
People resorted to eating household
pets like dogs and cats just in order to
survive.
Some even resorted to cannibalism.
In 1959 he was so unpopular that he
had to step down as the chairman of the
Communist Party and he handed over his
position as state chairman to a more
moderate party representative.
Thee shall Qui,
however,
mows it on,
continued to work in a leading position
in the governments and tried to run his
great leap forward from behind the scenes.
Instead of recognizing that his policy
was doomed to fail mouser dawn was
convinced that this was just bad luck
and it's press the people to keep going.
However,
people just continued
to die year after year.
Finally,
in 1961 the great leap forward,
it was canceled by the time
he finally ended the policy.
36 million people that died.
Yeah.
You'd think that after being responsible
for the deaths of millions of people
and somehow not being killed for it,
the had no,
it was time to quit,
but in 1966 miles of dawn trying to
regain the trust of the people and become
state chairman,
once again,
he has a place,
the blame for his mistakes somewhere else.
He claims that the Bosch was he the top
1% of society were ruining everything
and that Mao himself,
he was on the side of the peasants.
He builds up a cult of
personality and people,
they strongly supported
them again because well,
they remembered him as a revolutionary
hero who saved their country from the
Japanese and provided them with food
rations and free healthcare is fully was.
They were willing to
do whatever you asked.
He knew from his days as a college
student that young people were perfect for
molding into revolutionaries.
He convinced a group of students called
the Red God to seek out anyone who was
speaking out against the Communist Party.
He encouraged them to even murder their
professors who spoke against Mao's
policies just in order to
make an example of them.
According to some accounts smells,
red guards swept so savage,
they partook in flesh and banquets or
ritualistic cannibalism if their enemies
mouser dorm called the USSR and
North Korea treater revisionist.
See what bastardizing the
original work of Karl Marx.
His interpretation of communism was so
different from the rest of the world that
many people call his philosophy Maoism
instead of isolating is people from the
outside world like
other communist nations.
He encouraged globalization,
open trade,
which is why China's economy eventually
rebounded and did need this actually set
the stage for the economic
strength that China has today.
In 1968 the minister of Pakistan brought
a gift of 14 mangoes to chairman.
Now,
people of China had never
eaten tropical fruit before,
so this was a delicacy to them.
Now could impossibly
40 mangoes on his own,
so he hands down with the fruit twist
political team and a couple got in the
hands of a group of factory workers.
They were so mesmerized by this magical
sweet fruit that they literally started
to wash a bit saying that it was a
symbol of the wonderful new things that
Chairman Mao would bring to their land.
They taste it in a glass case
and when the freeway went bad,
they replaced it with a wax replica.
One man who had never tried mango before
questioned why everyone was worshiping
this piece of fruit.
He tried to compare it to a sweet potato.
You simply couldn't believe that
mangoes could taste so great.
Well then it got a little bit ridiculous
because even the mere suggestion that a
mango wasn't a magical fruit was
enough to kill a man for treason.
This is just one of many examples of
how irrationally devoted to Mouser Dong.
People were in the,
in 1970 when the country was
running low on building supplies,
Mouser don audit his workers to tear
down the Great Wall of China in order to
use the bricks to build new houses and
the damned you also destroyed engine dot
worker or anything else
that was considered to be a
symbol of the bourgeoisie.
He was willing to dismantle thousands of
years of Chinese history and culture in
order to execute is communist vision.
When he was getting older and Mouser
don was shameless when it came to you
reaping the benefits of
being a communist dictator.
You almost never bathed or brushed his
teeth and claims that he fenced himself
inside the bodies of his
mistresses and not surprisingly,
he contracted sexually transmitted
infections and spread them deep.
Several women who actually wore their
illness as something of a badge of honor
since it was given to
them by Chairman Mao.
Yup.
When he was in his sixties he appointed
a 16 year old girl named Jan Yufeng to
be his personal secretary.
She spent so much time with him that
even Mao Zedong's wife had to go through
January thing first before she could
make an appointment and speak with her
husband.
In 1973 he was sitting in a trade meeting
with Henry Kissinger and he reportedly
offered to trade 10 million
Chinese women to the United States.
He said that women caused
too many problems and that
it would be better to just
get rid of them.
In 1974 his third wife,
the beautiful actress Jane Chin,
decided that she would not sit
around waiting for husbands,
respect and affection.
She began gathering our own
collection of young male lovers.
She got so bold she wouldn't even allow
her boyfriend's do show up at the house
and now never protested against our fas.
When he died in 1976 people,
they were devastated him.
He was buried in a crystal caskets so
that people could see his body when they
came to visit lines of people
queued up to pay their respects,
and many of them openly,
when they saw the body
of their dear leader,
even to this day,
the memory of males are Dong is
revered by many as they remember him.
That's one of the great
heroes of the nation,
but loving more hasten China would be a
very different place today if it was not
for malice.
Saddam maybe without him trying to,
would have never become a
leading economic power house,
but maybe without seven millions of
people would not have died is the chairman
now,
not exactly the cheeriest of subjects,
but you know what,
can take the edge off his communist ways?
Well,
a cocktail,
and that's convenient because today's
video is brought to you by Shaker and
spirit.
Now,
no,
I'm not going to mix up some cocktails
at work because I'm not don draper.
So let's through the magic of
television and travel home.
Hello,
welcome to my home.
Let's make some cocktails.
Good.
So we have Shaker and spoon.
You get three cocktails that you
get to have a crack at this month.
They are the spice of life tea and
honey and the mighty creek cobbler.
Now I believe that gets them,
so we used one of these
hydrated mandarin wheels,
so I'm going to make this,
it's mostly with Irish whiskey and a
half a bottle of Irish whiskey on hand,
so that's a good thing.
First step,
I need to crush some ice.
Okay.
Now with Shaker and spoon,
it's available in the u s
obviously I'm not there,
so they make special accommodations
and send me this stuff internationally,
which I really appreciate.
They normally ship the fruit
with them I to by my own orange,
but don't worry everything you need
except for the booze comes in the box.
I also worry this orange is absolutely
massive and might not actually fit in my
gloss.
Okay.
This is a fine looking orange.
Good news or my needs it
bit them in the glass.
I should read the recipe I suppose
before I start with these things,
but the two big,
even when my shaker,
this is a ridiculously huge orange.
I'm just going to cut them in half and
put them in like that because apparently
my local shop sells mucins oranges,
one and a half ounces
of orange spice syrup.
This is it.
Go Myself.
One of these.
I always feel like it was such a
bartender we like and it makes that,
that nice ringing sound,
so put that in there.
Pop that in there.
Good.
A muddle of that.
Six seconds.
You know what's cool?
If you don't know what modeling is,
it tells you right here using a muddler
press fruit or herbs into the bottom of
the glass,
usually with added sugar or syrup.
When muddling.
Be careful not to destroy the fruit or
herbs you want to release their island
flavor.
Not Pulverize.
I didn't have a muddler.
I'm pretty sure they sent me a muddler.
I think I lost it.
I'm sorry.
Today we're using some Tullamore dew.
That in there.
Add that all in math.
Oh yeah.
Oh.
Dawnish we want on these bad boys.
Oh my God.
It is super good.
Thank you.
Shaker and spearing.
I'm sure you can all understand why this.
Probably one of my favorite sponsorships.
You know,
lots of useful stuff,
but this is the fun stuff.
You get $20 off your first box with
Shaker and spoon at sea on a link in the
description below to do that.
As always,
thank you for watching.
Thanks for Shaker in the spoon.
Back to the studio that is Shaker and
spirit and you can get $20 off your first
box.
They are going to Shaker [inaudible]
dot com slash biographics thanks.
Do you shake current and speaking for
the sponsorship and thanks to you for
watching.